Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Qui parmi vous a déjà dit à un enfant
lorsqu’il rentre de l’école,
ou à un élève,
pour ceux qui sont enseignants,
lorsqu’il revient avec une note
que l’on juge un peu insuffisante :
« Tu aurais dû travailler un peu plus.
La prochaine fois, il faudra faire
un peu plus d’efforts. »
Levez la main ceux qui ont déjà dit ça
à un enfant dans leur entourage.
(Rires)
On est nombreux, à ce que je vois.
Oui, on est nombreux à considérer
que, finalement, à l’école,
quand on s’en donne vraiment les moyens,
« quand on veut, on peut. »
D’ailleurs, de nombreux films,
de nombreuses publicités,
des ouvrages, sont là
pour bien nous rappeler
qu’avec la volonté, tout est possible.
Il est toujours possible d’accéder
à la réussite, même si l’on part de peu.
Croire que seuls la volonté et le travail
déterminent la réussite à l’école,
c'est croire au mérite scolaire.
Or, étudier les conséquences de la
croyance en la méritocratie scolaire
est une partie
de nos travaux de chercheurs
au Laboratoire de psychologie
sociale et cognitive
de l’Université Clermont Auvergne.
Lorsqu’on demande aux gens d’expliquer
ce qu’ils observent, par exemple :
« Pourquoi untel a réussi ?
Pourquoi untel a échoué ? »,
l’explication qui vient le plus
spontanément et le plus rapidement,
c’est une explication en termes d’effort.
« Il a dû travailler dur
pour en arriver là. »
C’est aussi le cas à l’école.
Et pour cause.
A l’école, les explications en termes
d’effort sont les plus valorisées.
En tant qu’enseignant, on aime bien
lorsqu’un élève ou un étudiant nous dit :
« J’ai réussi car j’ai bien travaillé »
ou « Je n’ai pas réussi parce
que je n’ai pas assez travaillé. »
On va préférer, et donc mieux évaluer, ce
type d’explication, donc ce type d’élève,
que lorsque l’élève mobilise
d’autres explications
qui sont davantage liées
à ses capacités, à la chance,
aux particularités de l’exercice,
par exemple sa difficulté.
Bien entendu, on a raison
de valoriser les efforts à l’école,
puisque les efforts,
c’est ce qui va permettre aux élèves
de progresser et d’apprendre,
de découvrir de nouvelles choses.
Donc l’effort est une condition
sine qua non à l’apprentissage.
Par ailleurs, croire
à l’efficacité de l’effort,
ça permet aux élèves
de garder un sentiment de contrôle.
C’est très utile pour persévérer
en cas de difficultés,
ne pas baisser les bras,
ne pas se résigner.
En ceci, croire au mérite scolaire,
c’est maintenir un certain niveau
de motivation, d’effort, de persévérance.
Mais, et c’est là qu’est le mais,
faire porter aux élèves la responsabilité
de la réussite et des échecs,
donc croire que l’école fonctionne
sur un mode purement méritocratique,
c’est promouvoir une vision du monde
dans lequel l’individu est le seul
responsable de ce qui lui arrive.
Si, quand on veut vraiment, on peut,
alors que dire de celui
qui ne réussit pas ?
Qu’il ne l’a pas assez voulu ?
Qu’il ne s’est pas suffisamment
donné les moyens de réussir ?
En bref, que c’est de sa faute ?
Promouvoir le mérite scolaire,
c’est faire porter la responsabilité
de la réussite ou de la difficulté
aux élèves, et exclusivement aux élèves.
C’est donc négliger d’autres facteurs
dont on sait pourtant
qu’ils sont très fortement corrélés
et prédisent très fortement la réussite
ou les difficultés rencontrées à l’école
ainsi que la durée des études :
l’origine sociale, le lieu d’habitation,
le genre, la couleur de la peau.
Autant de facteurs qui prédisent la
réussite scolaire et la durée des études
et qui pourtant n’ont pas grand-chose
à voir avec le mérite de chaque élève,
c’est-à-dire avec les efforts et avec
sa volonté de réussir dans ce système.
Croire en la méritocratie scolaire,
c’est penser que les personnes
diplômées méritent leur diplôme.
Et si elles méritent leur diplôme,
elles méritent aussi tous les privilèges
qui sont associés à leur possession.
Parce que oui,
il y a beaucoup de privilèges qui sont
associés à la possession de diplômes.
Dès lors, une différence de salaire,
de prestige, de statut
n’est plus perçue comme une injustice,
mais plutôt comme la répartition équitable
entre des individus
ayant beaucoup travaillé
et des individus ayant peu travaillé,
des individus s’étant donné
les moyens de réussir
et d’autres individus qui ont fait
un petit peu moins d’efforts.
Ainsi, croire au mérite scolaire
permet de justifier
les inégalités qui existent
entre les groupes.
Or, si les inégalités sont justifiées,
pourquoi souhaiterait-on changer
le système qui contribue à produire
et à reproduire ces inégalités ?
Je sens que, dans la salle, certains
d’entre vous doutent de mes propos.
Je vais donc partager
les résultats d’une étude
qui a été réalisée par
une équipe américaine récemment.
Cette étude a été réalisée
sur des enfants de 7 à 10 ans.
Lorsqu’ils arrivaient,
on leur demandait d’imaginer
qu’ils découvraient une nouvelle
planète, la planète Fleur.
Or, sur cette planète vivent différents
groupes : les Nifs et les Lups.
Or, sur cette planète,
les Nifs sont beaucoup
plus riches que les Lups.
Puis on demandait à l’enfant d’imaginer
qu’il allait rencontrer deux personnes,
un Nif et un Lup.
Conformément à la description
qui avait été donnée au préalable,
le Nif était plus riche que le Lup,
donc le Nif avait deux pièces alors
que le Lup n’en avait qu’une seule.
On donnait à chaque enfant une pièce
et on lui demandait de décider
à qui il souhaitait la donner.
Est-ce qu’il souhaitait donner cette pièce
au Nif, donc au plus riche des deux,
ou est-ce qu’il souhaitait la donner
au Lup, donc au moins riche des deux ?
C’est bon, vous me suivez ?
Alors, que vont faire les enfants
dans cette situation ?
Nif ? Lup ? Il y a un petit
peu des avis partagés.
Vous êtes sûrement nombreux à penser
que comme les enfants sont éduqués
dans l’idée qu’il faut partager,
probablement ils vont choisir
en grande majorité
de donner la pièce supplémentaire
à celui qui a moins, donc au Lup.
C'est ce qu'ils font dans certains cas,
mais pas toujours.
En réalité, cela dépend
d’explications qu’on a données
aux inégalités entre les Nifs et les Lups.
Dans un scénario,
on expliquait aux enfants
que la raison pour laquelle
les Nïfs sont plus riches
que les Lups sur cette planète
est qu’ils ont beaucoup de chance,
parce qu’il y a très longtemps,
des Nïfs ont trouvé de l’or
en arrivant sur la planète Fleur.
C’est pour ça.
Donc les Nïfs ont de la chance
de naître dans un groupe plus riche.
Dans un autre scénario,
la raison pour laquelle les Nifs et les
Lups n’ont pas le même niveau de richesse
est qu’en fait les Nifs ont naturellement
des capacités plus élevées que les Lups.
Ils sont plus compétents,
donc c’est pour ça qu’ils ont un niveau
de richesse plus élevé que les Lups.
Dans le dernier scénario,
on expliquait que les Nifs
étaient plus riches que les Lups
parce qu’ils avaient beaucoup travaillé.
Et c'est grâce à ce travail et ces efforts
qu'ils étaient devenus riches.
Alors ? Qu’ont montré
les résultats de cette étude ?
Quelles sont les stratégies
privilégiées par les enfants ?
Regardons d’abord
ce qu’il se passe dans les conditions
où les écarts de richesse
entre les Nifs et les Lups
sont présentés comme dus
à la chance ou aux capacités.
Dans ces cas-là, comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi,
les enfants sont plus nombreux
à faire le choix de la redistribution,
à donner la pièce supplémentaire
à celui qui en a le plus besoin,
c’est-à-dire à celui
qui a moins d’argent au départ.
Et en faisant ce choix-là,
ils restaurent l’égalité entre les deux.
Mais vous vous en doutez,
ce n’est pas ce qui se passe
lorsque l’explication fournie
pour justifier l’inégalité de richesse
repose sur la différence
d’effort et de travail.
Dans ce cas-là, que se passe-t-il ?
Eh bien, les enfants sont plus nombreux
à faire le choix
de perpétuer les inégalités,
c’est-à-dire qu’ils vont donner
la pièce supplémentaire au Nif
plutôt que la donner au Lup.
Pourquoi font-ils ça ?
Eh bien parce que dans cette situation,
le Nif est présenté
comme méritant sa richesse.
Qu’en est-il du Lup alors ?
Dans cette situation, le Lup est un peu
comme la Cigale des fables de La Fontaine.
Il n'a pas fait les efforts nécessaires
pour assurer sa survie.
Il ne mérite donc pas qu'on lui donne
la pièce de monnaie supplémentaire.
Il ne mérite pas qu'on l'aide.
Ainsi, les enfants sont plus enclins
à soutenir le principe de redistribution,
à corriger les inégalités,
lorsqu’elles sont présentées comme dues
à la chance ou à des capacités différentes
que lorsqu’elles sont présentées comme
relevant des efforts réalisés par chacun.
Il faut garder à l’esprit qu’en donnant
plus à celui qui a déjà beaucoup,
non seulement les enfants
vont perpétuer les inégalités,
mais ils vont également les renforcer,
puisque le Nif a désormais 3 pièces,
alors que le Lup, lui,
n’en a toujours qu’une seule.
Voilà pour les enfants.
Qu’en est-il des adultes ?
Je vais présenter maintenant
une autre recherche qu’on a réalisée
avec quelques collègues ici
sur des parents d’élèves français.
Voici le scénario.
Dans un premier temps,
on interroge ces parents d’élèves sur
leur croyance en la méritocratie scolaire.
Pour cela, on leur présente
une série d’affirmations
et on leur demande à quel point elles
correspondent à la réalité de l’école
telle qu'elle est en France aujourd'hui.
« A l’école, quand on veut, on peut. »
« Pour réussir, il suffit
de bien travailler. »
Cette mesure permet de faire la différence
entre les parents qui croient
fortement en la méritocratie scolaire
et ceux qui y croient un peu moins.
Ensuite, on présente aux parents
d’élèves une méthode fictive
qui s’appelle la méthode Alpha.
On leur explique qu’on travaille sur
cette nouvelle méthode pédagogique.
C’est donc une innovation pédagogique.
Les premiers résultats
sont très encourageants
parce que cette méthode semble améliorer
les performances des élèves.
Donc c’est super.
En particulier, cette méthode,
non seulement elle augmente
les performances de tous les élèves,
mais en plus elle permet
d’égaliser les performances
entre les élèves issus
de milieux défavorisés
et les élèves issus de milieux favorisés.
En ceci, cette méthode
est une méthode égalisante.
Ça, c’était pour la moitié des parents ;
pour l’autre moitié,
on présente cette méthode
comme améliorant les performances,
mais maintenant l’écart de performance
entre les élèves
issus de milieux défavorisés
et les élèves issus de milieux favorisés.
Donc la première méthode pédagogique
est une méthode égalisante
alors que la deuxième
est une méthode augmentante.
Les inégalités sont maintenues après
utilisation pendant plusieurs mois
de cette méthode
dans les salles de classe.
Ce qui nous intéresse ici, c'est de savoir
si les parents seraient favorables
à ce que cette méthode soit implémentée
dans l'école de leurs enfants.
Le sont-ils à votre avis ?
« Ça dépend. »
Vous avez raison de répondre ça.
Ça dépend en particulier de leur niveau
de croyance en la méritocratie scolaire.
Ce que l’on observe,
c’est que plus les parents croient
en la méritocratie scolaire,
moins ils soutiennent l’implémentation
de la méthode égalisante
dans l’école de leurs enfants.
Égalisante.
Mais ce n’est pas le cas
pour la méthode augmentante.
C’est donc bien la promotion de l’égalité
qui semble poser problème
aux parents qui croient fortement
en la méritocratie scolaire.
Rappelons qu’expliquer
réussite et échec scolaire
par l’effort ou le manque d’effort,
c’est quelque chose
que l’on fait très souvent.
Rappelons aussi que c’est utile
et qu’il faut continuer de le faire
parce que ça permet aux élèves
de progresser, d’avancer et de persister
lorsqu’ils sont confrontés
à une difficulté.
Toutefois faire la promotion
des efforts et du travail
comme seuls déterminants de la réussite
ou des difficultés rencontrées à l’école,
c’est faire porter beaucoup
de responsabilités à l’élève
et c’est propager une vision du monde
dans laquelle seuls les individus
sont responsables de ce qui leur arrive.
C’est donc négliger d’autres facteurs,
d’autres facteurs
qui sont pourtant déterminants.
Or, négliger ces facteurs, c'est
s'empêcher d'agir sur ces facteurs,
d’agir sur le système, d’agir sur l’école,
pour promouvoir davantage
d’égalité entre les groupes.
Je vous remercie de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)